انا ولدت قبل معادي من كتر الخوف والتوتر
والحرب والحرب اللي شفناها ولدت قيصري
بعمليه لاول مره اولد قيصري من التعب
والارهاق وتعذ من اول اسبوع وانا بجري في
البنت من نتفه لنفى من مدرسه لمدرسه من
مكان كل ما يقصفوا انا بعد ما كنت قاعده
عندهم سرير والبنت في الهواء على طول
نزلوني وقالوا لي خلص شوفي يعني مكان في
غيرك بده يجي وقعدنا نزاح يعني زي ما انت
شايفه في الحمامات وفي كله طوابير صار عنا
مالقيش لها البنت حليب و تخسني يعني انا
بدج ارضعها والله ما بنزل لها حليب اصلا
البنت طب ده و كل البلد مش لقلك علبه
حلاوه انك تعوضي البنت حاجه
شي حتى في الميلاد اعبت كل الكاتر كانت
حواليه وفيش يعني هدف اني اقدر اطلق
بالمره بالمره كانت حالتي سيئه جدا
وكان الجنين بده يروح بين ايدي صرخ
الدكتور على كل الممرضات يجوا حوالي لان
فان باللا مره ما قدرتش اطلق انا بعد
الولاده قعدت يعني ساعات لان فيش وسع كان
كثير بوالده بس بوالده على السريع دغر
خوها خمس ساعات ترتاح وبعدين بروحوا على
المشفى قعدت في المقوى والمقوى كان في 80
2 فرد يعني كيف تتحملي الضوضاء شش تتحملي
بدايه الحرب كانت
القصف عنيف يعني مخيف بالنسبه لتاسع
الوحده لا قادره تتحرك ما بتقدري تجري ما
بتقدري يعني حتى لو بدك تطلعي ما بتقدري
يعني رحت على المستشفى طبعا فات م عادي
يعني حكوي صار يحكوا لي مع الخوف صار يروح
المخاض صاروا يحكوا لي لازم تمشي في
ساعتين زمن وترجعي لنا وين نمشي في
المناطق
قصف مناطق الرباط وشارع كمال العدوان هذا
كله مهدم بتبق في غرفه الولاده والسام
الداف يعني انت خايفه من المخاض ولا خايفه
من القصف اللي برا اصلا يعني القصف كان
حوالين المستشفى العوده محظره كانت
المستشفى
كانت طوارئ وطبعا في تحت غير اللي بيجي شه
هذا بتسمع سراخ ا بقى كله هذا توتر
وخوف انزل على الدرج يقولوا لي في صيانه
في غرفه الولاده ارجعي اطلعي طبعا انت لا
مش قادره تتحمل طبعا الوجع كمان فش كهرباء
وفيش كان عين
يا بعد الولاده بكم يوم اللي هو صار
منطقتنا لازم نخل قلنا خلص نروح على
الجنوب طلعنا قالوا على طريق صلاح الدين
طريق صلاح الدين فش يعني يا اما على
الكرات يا اما بدك تمشي وايش ما كان والده
ال كم من يوم مشيت كنت قادره يعني تعبانه
وحامله بنت ولا قادرين نحمي لواع ولا شيء
ممنوع ومرينا بعدين وصلنا الحاجز الدبابات
واليهود طبعا واقفه ساعتين ممنوع تنزلي
ولا تقعدي ولا تملي تظلك رافعه هويتك
وحامله البنت البنت ممنوع تنزليها على
الارض الطمبله صاروا يقولون بمل
بقناص
بطخه